rossi artikeln
[Musik]
mit prozess eve artikeln können wir
ausdrücken dass personen und sachen
zusammen gehören
archiv artikel sind also nützliche
kleine helfer
hier ein erstes beispiel
das ist ein fußball
wem gehört der fußball
das ist mein fußball
mein ist hier also der prozess lief
artikeln
in der deutschen sprache hat jede person
ihren prozess artikeln
schauen wir sie uns genauer an
es wird zum 1
ich würde zum 1
wird zu sein du wird zu sein
hallo feelings hallo simon ist das dein
hund ist das dein hund ja das ist mein
hund ja das ist mein hund
der ist aber süß wie heißt dein hund wie
heißt dein hund
mein hund heißt da wie mein hund heißt
duffy oder es wird zu sein oder es wird
zu sein
sein hund heißt duffy sein hund heißt
duffy sie wird zu ihr
sie wird zu ihr und wie heißt ihr hund
und wie heißt ihr und ihr hund heißt
daisy ihr hund heißt daisy ist das
wirklich ihr hund ist das wirklich ihr
hund ja das ist ja das ist ihrer und
meiner macht wieder was er will und
meiner macht wieder was er will
hier wird zu unser wir wird zu unser ihr
wird zur wird zu halo simon hallo felix
darf ich dir meine neue freundin
vorstellen darf ich dir meine neue
freundin vorstellen
ihr name ist anna ihr name ist anna
hallo anna schön dich kennenzulernen
schön dich kennenzulernen
hallo simon
es freut mich kennenzulernen
ist das euer und ist das euer und ja das
ist unser hund ja das ist unser hund
genau genommen ist er anders hund genau
genommen ist er anders rund sein name
ist falco sein name ist falco und was
ist mit duffy geschehen sagt bloß hast
du ihn weg gegeben
nein der muss hier irgendwo sein aber
der körper macht immer noch was er will
lust auf einen kaffee
lust auf einen kaffee und jetzt noch
einige beispiele die dir ebenfalls
helfen können
der tisch
das ist mein tisch
das ist sein tisch
das ist ein sehr
na tisch
das ist ein sehr schöner tisch
ist das wirklich deinen tisch
ja das ist meiner
tisch gehört meiner mutter
ich gehörte meiner mutter
es war
ja
es war irre
er war
von ihr
er war ein geschenk von ihr
hat ihn mir geschenkt als ich von zu
hause ausgezogen bin
die tische
das sind meine tische
das sind
tische
das sind ihre tische
sind das wirklich deine tische
ja
das sind meine
das war
die tische meines vaters
waren die tische meines vaters
die tische waren auch ein geschenk
das war sehr großzügig von ihm
ach weißt du ich glaube er hat noch
welche in seinem keller
wir könnten etwas mehr platz brauchen in
unserem keller
do
hast recht liebling
hätten unsere stühle auch noch platz
das regal
die regale
das ist sein regal
ist ihr egal
sind unsere regale
bin ich verwirrt
ist das
ein regal
ist das jetzt ein regal
das ist dein
und dieses hier ist mainz
dieses hier ist mainz
die lampe
die lampen
lampen
das ist ihre lampe
das ist seine lampe
unsere lampen
einen moment mal
ist das jetzt deine oder meine lampe
das jetzt deine oder meine lampe
ist das wirklich dein ernst
das ist deine
und das ist meine
das ist
ich nicht mein tag
da hast du wohl recht
heute ist wirklich nicht sein tag
der stuhl
stühle
du meinen neuen stuhl
magst du meinen neuen stuhl
diese stuhl sieht sehr bequem aus
dieser stuhl sieht sehr bequem aus
ist das dein stuhl
das war der stuhl meines bruders
oder war es der stuhl meiner schwester
das
der stuhl meines bruders
oder war es der stuhl meiner schwester
ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern
ich weiß nur dass es jetzt meiner ist
[Applaus]
das haben sie wirklich toll gemacht
das video hilfreich für dich
schreibe es in die kommentare bis zum
nächsten
[Musik]
vergiss nicht das video zu leiden
kommentiere und abonniere unseren kanal
[Musik]